award-winning actress Marcia Cross is
perhaps best known for her role is the
perfect homemaker on the TV series
Desperate Housewives we remember her she
was diagnosed with anal cancer about a
year and a half ago after Kraus
completed radiation and chemotherapy she
reached out to our doctor Jon LaPook to
share her story
John kudos to her for discussing
something so personal yeah and yeah
among other things Marcia Cross is
hoping to break down the taboo
surrounding anal cancer I first met her
at a stand up to Cancer Fund racing back
in 2010 and at the time her husband Tom
was being treated for throat cancer
thankfully Tom and Marcia are now both
doing well but it turns out their
cancers are likely related just a
reminder this will be a frank discussion
using words that might make some people
uncomfortable I was so not thinking
anything was wrong because I didn't have
any symptoms and she gave me an exam and
she kind of came around and said well I
just want you know whatever it is it's
curable or you're just like what what
are you talking about it it was during a
visit to Marcia Cross's gynecologist
that a routine digital rectal exam
revealed a cancerous mass why do you
want to talk about this now because I
know that there are people who are
ashamed you have cancer do you have to
then like also feel ashamed
like you did something bad you know
because it took up residence in your
anus I mean come on really there's
enough on your plate I love the way
you've embraced the word meanness yeah
even for me it took a while ain't a
saint a saint isn't you have to just get
used to it I'm feeling better now
besides every bake sale needs
at RZT best known as Bree van de Kamp on
Desperate Housewives Marsha spent eight
years serving up and showing off her
many talents
how would gray have handled the
diagnosis he would have told a soul and
how many people are just like that
many many many people breaks my heart
according to the CDC human
papillomavirus or HPV causes more than
90% of anal cancers the same virus can
also cause cancer of the cervix genitals
and throat it can spread from one person
to another through sex or just by
skin-to-skin contact Cross says her
annual rectal exam saved her life
this is embarrassing this is
uncomfortable and by the time you know
what it's it's over and you I mean lots
of things in life err not fun but you
can bear it during six weeks of
radiation then two weeks of chemo Kraus
leaned on her closest friends what I had
was a bevy of girlfriends I called them
my anal angels yeah you know I kept
saying if this doesn't kill me it's like
the best thing that could have ever
happened because the experience of being
loved like that they blew my mind back
in 2009 as her twin daughters were
turning to her husband Tom Mahoney was
diagnosed with throat cancer and began
treatment I would be like working all
day I would be in the emergency room at
night less I had two toddlers so it was
a it was a busy time
a grueling regimen put Mahoney in
remission but what Kraus didn't know
then was the same type of HPV that
likely triggered his throat cancer can
also cause cancer in the anus in 2019 an
estimated 8300 people will be diagnosed
with anal cancer however the types of
HPV that most commonly cause cancer can
be prevented by the current vaccine
as a parent Kross was relieved to learn
early immunization can protect the next
generation my girls don't know it but
they're they're up for their first shot
mmm the end of the school year they're
12 12 it's been about a year and a half
since your diagnosis how are you doing
I'm doing great
I feel back to normal
although it's a new normal I don't think
I'll ever take it for granted
okay I'm the girl who goes to the
bathroom now and I go yes right what you
my body can do I'm so grateful I'm like
yes
statistically anal cancer is on the rise
Marsha hopes that sharing her story will
help others get up a nerve to talk with
their clinicians about what may be
embarrassing symptoms like rectal
bleeding a lump in the area of the anus
or a change in bowel habits it's better
to be embarrassed and alive at listen we
all have one but nobody wants to talk
about it because you get such a graphic
image in Europe in your brine so what
kind of doctor do you go to to get
bitten you know we reached out to five
different societies including ones that
handle people in internal medicine OBGYN
family practice and there are no
official recommendations about a rectal
exam about who should get it when it
should be done there's this thing called
shared decision-making that's good that
means you know what we're kind of plenty
to the doctor and the patient the
clinician the patient talk about it and
I think one of the things that's
happening even the pelvic exam is no
longer recommended for everybody
routinely so with Marsha that was picked
up on routine digital exam and and you
pointed a digital meaning with your
fingers that the digit you mentioned at
the HPV vaccine can prevent this kind of
cancer potentially our young people
getting those shots you know they they
are increasingly but it's still just
under 50% and so it's something you know
it's part of this anti vaccine or
vaccine hesitant thing that's going on
I think the punchline here is people
have to feel empowered to talk to their
physician talk to their clinicians about
it and these societies I think it may be
time with the increasing incidence of
this problem to go redress these guys
dr. Jon LaPook thank you very much we
got to go here